now turning to the economy the Federal
Reserve has raised interest rates again
yesterday by three quarters of a
percentage point for the third time this
year is part of a continuing effort to
slow inflation but it could mean a
recession when times like this happened
we lean on one a few people CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger she is
here to break it all down so what does
this mean for consumers there are always
winners and losers so let's start with
the losers borrowers anyone who's
carrying a credit card balance you're
going to get a new auto loan maybe you
have an adjustable rate mortgage and
it's going to adjust higher maybe it's a
small business loan that's all going to
cost you more but on the flip side there
are winners Savers are doing a happy
dance they are finally getting more
money credited to their money market
their savings accounts their uh their
checking accounts and it's been a long
time since we've seen that so for
consumers it is a mixed bag speaking of
time what about the timing why is the
Fed doing this right now well inflation
remains incredibly high so we found out
that we know that overall inflation
Rising by 8.3 percent from a year ago
but every single category internally
Rising food shelter energy and all of
these things eat up so much of a
household's budget the fed's got to
raise rates slow down the economy so
that inflation starts to come down and
so far it has not been successful in
pushing down that inflation rate more
increases to come absolutely in the
fed's projections they're seeing another
1.25 percent before the end of the year
there are two more meetings one in
November one in December additional rate
hikes next year so when we're looking
forward to maybe six eight months from
now we're looking at the FED funds rate
at around 4.6 percent it was at zero to
a quarter of a percent just a year ago
there's people at home that are
wondering are we headed towards uh
recession you say it not me
um look every time the FED raises rates
the likelihood of a potential recession
Rises for sure why because raising
interest rates is a blunt instrument it
takes a while for those interest rate
increases to filter through the economy
and to be clear higher interest rates
are meant to slow things down but they
can slow down too much so most
economists are looking ahead and saying
will likely be in a recession next year
hopefully it is a short and shallow
recession
y'all thank you so much